learning loss caused by kovids
specifically school lockdowns and
distance learning has school districts
across the country scrambling here is
what ccsd is doing to try and get our
kids back to grade level
ccsd students falling behind getting
some good answers here in addition to
mental health impact coveted closures
led to learning loss ccsd deputy
superintendent brenda larson-mitchell
acknowledges it's an issue our data is
demonstrates that our students struggled
last school year only 41 percent of
students showed proficiency in english
just 26 percent in math the biggest drop
with the youngest students
we wanted to go beyond the test scores
and dig into tangible crucial steps
being taken to right the ship it's going
to take all of us
to ensure that our students are
successful first figuring out who is
struggling academically emotionally or
both based on those assessment results
we look at each individual child and we
determine what levels of support
or intervention do they need to be
successful
ccsd is implementing an array of
interventions additional study time
smaller group instruction tutoring extra
math and reading classes and summer
acceleration programs will it work we
have to we have to
our administrators our teachers our
licensed professionals our support
professionals are working extremely
extremely hard parents can also help
with learning recovery math what i do is
i have my mom and dad nearby me and they
times
multiplication and division i make sure
they understand the importance of a good
education separate from test scores the
surgeon general now warns of a mental
health crisis among kids so you take a
kid and they thrive on two things so
they thrive on routine
and they thrive on social interaction
and they lost both of those this led to
an increase in anxiety depression
self-harm even suicide pervasively we
were seeing
anxiety and fear ccsd is using a
baseline panorama survey that allows
professionals to reach those most in
need we can catch kids that may be
hitting that red
where they need immediate attention
outreach counseling connecting with
parents they need to talk and that's
what we're trying to reteach kids to do
they sat behind a computer far more
students are now seeking therapeutic
help at least 70 percent more wow for
many kids distance learning had a
devastating impact on emotional
well-being and school closures led to
significant learning losses can ccsd
assure parents kids will stay in school
we are very committed we are committed
to keeping our schools open
working to get all students back to
grade level when we're a united
group of educators and parents
and the student there's nothing that we
can't do
parents if you are concerned your child
is falling behind get involved you can
always contact their school for extra
tutoring additional resources and some
help in creating a plan for a return to
success